[Music]
riley starts off this hour in sioux
falls south dakota hi riley how are you
hey dave doing well how about you better
than i deserve how can george and i help
good some quick background info here i'm
26 my wife is 24 and we have a
three-month-old baby yay
we i recently graduated from physical
therapy school in may and just just
started working and my wife will be
finishing up her pt school here in may
this coming may
um so we have a total we have a total of
161 000 in loans student loans all
student loans
um
and
we currently have 30 000 on in cash
right now
but we'll have 18 000 after we pay for
this next her next semester here coming
up
um i'm sorry when did she graduate
this coming may may 2022
okay so that's the last semester
correct this is yep okay so that no more
expenses after you pay that 18 out of
the 30. correct okay uh 12 12 out of the
30 18 left over yeah
yep
um what do you make so my biggest
uh my monthly take home is about 56.
right fifty fifty six hundred right now
so you're making like seventy thousand
bucks what's she gonna be making about
the same
yeah about that maybe a little less yeah
so 70 grand or so okay
each each yeah so about 140 000 okay
yeah and so my question is since i'm
making payments on my loans right now do
we do my loan smallest to largest and
start knocking those out or do we just
add them all up hers included
um since she's not making payments and
just do it all together smallest largest
yeah i mean this is uh our debt now
since you're married so i would just
pile them all smallest to largest and
start plowing through those and because
you're going to start to feel the
progress and you're cash flowing the
remainder of first school which is great
because you're not adding to this this
pile of debt but you guys are going to
have a great income coming out of this
and you know you take on an extra side
job you slash the budget down you're
going to get rid of this stuff real fast
when the
last payment is made on the 161 000
it will not have changed the date
by a dime
due to your starting one or the other
first
okay but it doesn't change it
so it just george is right it doesn't
you know she's out in six months you got
six more months before you have to start
paying
but um you know and if you want to set
hers aside because there's no payments
on them and just start plunking through
yours first and then when hers activate
six months after graduation
approximately a year from now
you could add them back in at that point
and start attacking them because they're
not draining anything on you right now
with no payments being made right
correct uh her undergrad are federal so
it's obviously stopped with that and no
interest um her and she also has private
loans for grad school which are it all
ought to be on hold though because she's
still in school
and it's all on hold till six months
after she graduates right
correct yep regardless of covid
yes sir okay so that six i mean six
months before she graduates and six more
months proximately puts us back here at
this time next year for her start
i mean you could go either way i i may
want to go your direction just because i
like getting rid of some of the payments
that you've got
and that's what i was thinking too yeah
we weren't sure where to start so
it's okay to go either way
uh george george's point of working
together to knock out both of them is a
big deal so 100
when her payments come due the first
month you reset your debt snowball and
integrate the two over
with each other right
perfect yep that makes total sense yeah
but if you're if you're going to go
ahead and knock yours out first in the
meantime how many little ones have you
got can you knock out in a year
um
my lowest balance is about
10 thousand so
hopefully i'm not sure three or four
oh wow okay so you're gonna get after it
good
well and she'll start work and and
shortly after she finishes graduation
and so forth yeah yeah i'm in that'll
give you a nice raise when she starts
working this if you can get your
expenses down to nothing and you've got
11k take home coming in you're going to
knock these student loans out really
fast if you guys get after it make sure
you're not having too much withheld too
in the process so hey good job man good
job thanks for calling in